Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
Titelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
Erzähl mir ein bisschen darüber, was du das letzte Jahr am meisten überrascht hast und was du dieses Jahr am meisten hier überrascht hast.
Oh, wow. Ja, 2018, ich glaube, eine große Lektion war, wie viel die Leute Lindsay Sterling lieben.
Sie war einer unserer beendeten Performerinnen und sie war tatsächlich unser höchstwertiger Performer von den Attendees.
Also ja, ich denke, es war...
Und die Gäste für uns, dass wir Talent haben wollen, das für die Gemeinschaft relevant ist, das in der Gaming-Szene ist, das war großartig.
Und dieses Jahr haben wir so viel Neues.
Und ich bin wirklich gespannt auf das Blizzard-Arcade, das unten in Hall E ist.
Ich hoffe, dass alle es anschauen werden. Es hat neue Sachen und es hat auch Retro-Sachen, die wir wirklich gespannt haben.
Auch unten ist unser Cinema, das wir für Familien oder jemanden, der nicht maturen Inhalte sehen will, hoffen, dass sie in den Cinema in Hall E gehen werden.
Aber es gibt noch andere Dinge, über die ich noch nicht ganz sprechen kann, für die wir hoffen, dass alle super gespannt sind.
Oh, ich bin sicher, es gibt immer Dinge, die du uns nicht erzählen kannst.
Gibt es irgendwelche Hinten oder Dinge, für die wir bereit sein wollen?
Ich weiß, dass du uns keine Spoiler geben kannst, aber wie sollen wir uns vorbereiten?
Oh mein Gott, ähm, naja, es werden große Erinnerungen geben, es werden großartige Filme geben, wie immer, wir werden von Hall D bis zu Hall C gehen, und wir haben drei Stagen mit der gesamten Produktion zusammen, und außer dem sollten wir nichts teilen.
Na ja, wenn Leute zuhause mit einem virtuellen Ticket schauen, werden sie vielleicht noch nicht herausgefunden haben, was sie bekommen werden und was sie verlieren werden, wenn sie kein virtuelles Ticket haben.
Oh, okay, gute Frage.
Also...
Well, first of all, the virtual ticket comes with all these in-game goodies, uh, so this year we have, like, two, uh, Murloc Pets and World of Warcraft, and this awesome, uh, uh, onesie, like this Yeti onesie for WoW, we've got two legendary heroes, uh, for, um, for Overwatch, and so there's lots of in-game goodies to check out, but then also live at the show, we really want the virtual ticket to be the best way to experience BlizzCon, if you can't actually be there and online, yeah, so we have, uh, you know, additional 25 hours of content that people can watch just from the comfort of their home, on their couch, uh, so yeah, I hope that's a great experience.
Now, one thing I wanna ask you, cause we always talk about what Blizzard is bringing to BlizzCon, but you mentioned the community and making sure that things are relevant to them, what are you most excited that the community is going to bring here to BlizzCon to you?
Oh, that's by far my favorite part, uh, the cosplay, I really just love the cosplay, I love Community Night, I love the March of the Murlocs, we did that for the first time last year, we really weren't, we weren't sure how it was gonna go, so we had six employees in one season, we needed them, and then, like, hundreds of people showed up, so that was awesome, we're doing that again.
Cosplay, Cosplay Gathering, so all that is adorable, I mean, I'm supposed to making the show all year, so I kinda know about the big things that Blizzard's doing, but I just love, all weekend we'll be taking photos of what we want to bring to the show, I love it.
I can't wait to see it, and I can't wait to see the opening ceremony, so we're gonna head that way right now, but thank you so much.
Alright, back to you guys.
Thank you, Anna and Sarah Lynn, uh, she's keeping it tight-lipped, man.
I'm so hyped right now.
Okay, let's take a look, we've got a lot of great guests coming on the show today, here's everybody lined up.
This is Friday, uh, here on the pre-show we're gonna have Sam Braithwaite, he is the eSports Global Director, so we're gonna find out about everything going down, with all the championship games happening.
So hopefully he can break down some StarCraft, some Hearthstone, some StarCraft, FDI and Arena.
Ein Text, keine Mediasource, okay.
I wanna talk World Cup with him, that's gonna be fun, that's gonna be fun to see what he thinks about Overwatch World Cup.
Definitely, definitely, and we've got, uh, Jalen Brack coming to the desk as well, right after opening ceremony, the president of Blizzard Entertainment.
Ah, Reed from File, ah.
Uh, I can't wait for the Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
And, uh, tomorrow, uh, we're gonna have tons of illustrious guests as well.
Yeah.
Uh, K.O. Milker's gonna be joining us to talk some heroes of the Storm.
K.O. Milker, me and him have a little bit of a personal attachment, that was the first guy I've ever interviewed at Blizzard.
No way!
So, that's gonna be fun.
That's awesome, I'm excited for Ian Hazekostas, he's the World of Warcraft Games Director, and, uh, we have a lot to talk about.
Reloaded us, ah.
Yeah.
I am, uh, I have a lot of Sylvanas questions for him, so.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, okay.
Okay.
I am excited, Kaune, am Start.
Uh, guys, uh, now that you know who's gonna be stopping by, you can start tweeting us questions for all of your guests with the hashtag BlizzCon2019, and if you have questions for Michelle and I, you can tweet those as well.
We will be looking, and at the end of the day, we're gonna be sending you guys over to the Community Night for the Tela and Costume Contest, and, um, every single year, these costumes keep getting bigger and better and more elaborate.
The craftsmanship that goes into these things is amazing.
So, if you love Blast, like, you definitely don't wanna miss it.
Look at that, look at that!
How many hours do they spend?
How much time do they spend making these costumes?
You know, no joke, some people spend like a year doing this, all year long.
So, uh, I'm excited to see what I will come up with.
Somebody come up with a Sigma and have new shoes on.
They better get a pedicure.
They better walk around with no shoes on.
Uh, guys, the Talent Contest should also be pretty epic this year.
Have no fear.
They are back to defend their title after winning it all, and they'll be going up against another man.
Bob Ramby will be trying to break through for their first community night and night.
This is his own little competition that we're having here amongst all the esports.
This is like his own little thing happening here.
It's true, it's been going on for a long time.
So, as you guys can see, we got a lot happening for you guys over the next two days.
If you wanna see it all, you're gonna need the BlizzCon virtual ticket, which is available right now on blizzcon.com.
Your purchase is gonna be a lot by 25 hours of live and on-demand Blizzard content,
giving you guys full access to every stage, every panel, every inch of the Anaheim Convention Center.
You're also gonna receive some bonus in-game items.
That's Sarah Lynn Smith, I've mentioned.
Everything in the Blizzard universe, including a pair of Murloc faction leaders for WoW.
One that looks like Sylvanas.
We have a lot of free skins for Overwatch.
Legendary skins?
I'm on board.
But, uh, guys, right now, you're watching our free preview.
And it's going up in the past.
It ends right after opening ceremony.
But this year, there's so much going on.
There's so much exciting stuff to talk about that for the first time ever,
that for the first time ever,
we're spending a free window all the way until 1.30 p.m.
So now you'll have a full six hours to check out the incredible wall-to-wall Blizzcon coverage
we're offering here on the all-access channel.
Super cool.
I don't think we've ever been live.
Yeah, I don't think we've ever even done that.
Nope.
So, guys, if you want to continue watching after that and all day tomorrow,
you can pick up a virtual ticket on blizzcon.com.
And no matter how you guys choose to watch, experience Blizzcon,
whether you're at home or whether you're here with us today,
you're going to want to download the new and improved Blizzcon mobile app for iOS and Android.
It's got a ton of features on it.
You can cast your favorite stream with Airplay and Chromacat.
Yeah.
My personal opinion is that it's not worth it at all to buy the ticket.
With an interactive app, you can watch live streams and on-demand video content.
And probably my favorite thing about the app is that you can create your own custom schedule.
So that you can never miss anything that way if you're on a panel
and you want to see a different panel, you can put it all lined up in the app.
Yeah.
The FAQ-Panel is eh das, wo der RedShirt-Guy immer rumspringt.
Der war aber letztes Jahr nicht da.
Mal gucken, ob der dieses Jahr da ist.
Es ruckelt übrigens. Das bin nicht ich.
Wollte ich bloß mal sagen.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Es kann übrigens sein, dass ich während gerade was läuft,
nicht dazwischen labere, was Subs und so angeht.
Aber ich finde es super, dass ihr alle am Start seid,
weil ich sammle mich am Ende.
Ich gucke zwischendrin schon noch, ne.
Wen haben wir denn heute? Den Friedrich.
Underscore, Underscore, Underscore, Underscore haben wir am Start.
SVW, Paddy und JokeGaming, Offi.
Erik ist stolz.
Edgelord.
Ted Klados.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Huge.
Oh! Woodface!
Original Woodface.
Wir sind hier in der Arena.
Wir haben so viele Fans.
Wir sind gespannt auf die Eröffnungszeremonien.
Meine Damen und Herren, seid ihr bereit für BlizzCon?
Ich habe euren Are You Ready gestohlen.
Oh! Erik ist stolz.
5 Abos.
Huge Gift.
Ja, bei ihm flippen sie mehr aus.
Ist das hier Mercy-Cosplay?
Das bringt Teams aus der Overwatch-Kommunikation von überall um die Welt.
Hier in Anaheim, Kalifornien, um zu kämpfen.
Erzähl mir, warum dieses Event so speziell für dich ist.
Eigentlich schon für die 5 Subs.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Glück und habt einen gekriegt.
Es ist einfach toll, mit der Community zu Hause zu sein.
Und während wir in den Overwatch-League-Finals waren, war es großartig.
Es ist eine tolle Chance, den Fans zu zeigen, wie stolz sie sind.
Ob ihr für Team-USA cheert,
der vielleicht wieder in Südkorea verliert,
Doch.
Definitiv.
Südkorea hat Autowin in Overwatch.
Easy Twitch Mason.
Easy Sub, Easy Life.
Also Leute, wer ernsthaft glaubt,
dass irgendein anderes Land außer Südkorea
den Overwatch World Cup gewinnt,
der ist nicht mehr von dieser Welt im Hirn.
Das gilt für LoL.
Ja, für LoL gilt das auch.
Das gilt für fast, das gilt für alle E-Sports, die Koreaner spielen.
Also sag mir, was du über die Luft gesehen hast,
und was du am meisten gespannt hast, was hier bei BlizzCon stattfindet.
Weißt du, ich will nur wissen, was das Zukunft hat.
Das ist es.
Ich will nur wissen, was wir im nächsten Jahr haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Leute kommen zu mir und sagen, oh ja.
Du hast die Chancen, du hast die Chancen, du hast die Chancen.
Ich habe nichts.
Niemand sagt diesem Boom oder was auch immer, und es frustriert mich.
Ich will nur wissen, was das Gute ist,
und wir werden das in ein bisschen Zeit herausfinden.
Es wird großartig sein.
Absolut.
Wir kommen näher und näher an die Eröffnungszeremonie.
Also Alex, ich werde dich zurück an die Overwatch-Weltcup-Führung senden.
Meine Damen und Herren, ich werde dich brauchen, um deine Schuhe in den Sitz zu halten,
weil es Zeit ist, sie zurück zu Malik und Michelle zu senden,
um uns so näher zu bringen.
Rachel, vielen Dank.
Und vielen Dank, Golden Boy.
Okay, wir sind jetzt hier am Tisch.
Das ist eine andere.
Sam Braithwaite für BlizzCon E-Sports.
Hallo, hallo.
Die sahen sich doch übelst ähnlich aus.
Die sehen sich doch total ähnlich.
Ja.
Die hier und die, die eben die Blizzard-Producerin interviewt hat,
die sahen sich doch saumäßig ähnlich aus.
Ich dachte, das ist die gleiche.
Ich dachte, das ist hier die Frau von InControl.
Das hat mich echt geschockt, muss ich ehrlich mal sagen.
Mit InControl.
Es sind so viele Leute in den letzten Jahren jung gestorben.
Total BlizzKid, InControl, Internet Hulk.
Der Wahnsinn, ey.
Da habe ich mit 35, da habe ich ja schon fast Panik,
dass ich demnächst den Löffel abgebe.
Okay, ich habe jetzt nicht wirklich geklärt, wer ist das?
Classic.
Ist Classic nicht der StarCraft-Spieler mit dem riesen Kinn?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja.
Kennt man eigentlich alle auf der Bühne? Nee, nee, nee.
Ich kenne da eh wenig. Seit Madsen weg ist, seit, boah, wie wird hier immer die Ausgabe
von Morhaime, Morhaime-Dings weg ist und viele, und noch ein paar andere, ich kenne kaum noch
welche auf der Bühne. Einzigen, den wir kennen, ist Jeff Jeff. Jeff Jeff kommt dann
nachher wieder für Overwatch. Also Leute, ich predikte jetzt mal was, kurz bevor es
losgeht.
Diablo 4 halte ich für, halte ich für irgendwie logisch, ja. Also das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen,
dass Diablo 4 kommt. Overwatch 2, ganz ehrlich, Leute, ich habe meine Zweifel, ob Overwatch
2 das sein wird, was wir uns vorstellen. Ich könnte mir nämlich eher vorstellen, dass
es sowas sein wird wie Fortnite Season 2, dass man quasi Overwatch 1 aufbohrt zu Overwatch
2 mit, äh, selbst ob es eine Kampagne gibt, bin ich, bin ich nicht.
Bin ich skeptisch. Ich, ich gehe davon aus, dass man aus Overwatch 1 quasi Overwatch 2
macht, so wie bei Fortnite und, ähm, das Logo ein bisschen ändert, so quasi, so, so nach
dem Motto Relaunch. Ob es eine Kampagne geben wird, weiß ich nicht. Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es ein bisschen mehr Competitive PvE geben wird und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass
es irgendwelche weiteren Level-Mechanics geben wird oder verschiedene Skills für die Helden
oder so, weil ganz ehrlich, das Meta ist so stale in Overwatch immer und Blizzard patcht
so langsam, dass es einfach langweilig ist. Und wenn du verschiedene Skillsets hättest
für Helden, könnte das einiges bringen. Müssen wir mal gucken. Ich rechne definitiv mit irgendeiner
größeren Overwatch-Sache.
Dort sollte es aber eigentlich losgehen, oder?
Es muss losgehen jetzt. 30 Sekunden haben sie noch.
Just seeing all those different teams coming together and, one, the community surrounding
the eSports competition was awesome, but to see all the different people from different
countries coming and battling it out, it was really cool to kind of see who played well
against who. There's some teams that have never even played against each other before.
And so, it was really interesting to see how the different metas kind of came together.
What's it been like for you? I mean, you know, I've been doing this show for six years.
What's it been for you to watch eSports grow to what it is today?
It's been awesome. It feels like just yesterday I was here and the fans, äh,
watching eSports grow.
Warcraft 3 being competed.
Right?
And now we're here, we have, what, four games and five competitions across two days.
I remember when it was just StarCraft Warcraft.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ja, Alter, das ist 15 Jahre her. Jetzt übertreibt man nicht. Die meisten Leute, die jetzt hier
zugucken, haben Warcraft 3 überhaupt noch mal mitgekriegt.
Yeah.
That's what BlizzCon's all about, you know what I mean?
What arena are you going to be sitting in?
Ich würde gerne wieder Overwatch spielen, wenn da was Gescheites kommt.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock, mich die ganze Zeit aufzukriegen.
Sam, thank you so much for coming and joining us.
Man hat mal Gandhi, danke schon für den Sub.
Thanks, guys.
So, jetzt geht's los.
Geh los!
Let's see how you guys are gearing up for BlizzCon on social media right now.
Yeah.
And actually, you know what?
Before we do that, let's go ahead and toss things right over to Mythic.
Oh, we're going to check in on Mythic Hall again.
Mythic Hall, what's going on?
I guess we're still here for us.
19 Uhr sollte es eigentlich losgehen, ne?
Ich seh's ja nochmal.
Okay, es geht los.
How are you feeling, BlizzCon?
Danke für den Sub, STBA.
Before we start the opening ceremony, I want to say a few words.
You know, Blizzard had the opportunity to bring the world together.
Wird geschleimt.
In a tough, Hearthstone eSports moment.
Oh je.
Hongkong.
We did not.
Hongkong kommt jetzt.
We moved too quickly in our decision making.
And then, to make matters worse, we were too slow to talk.
With all of you.
When I think about what I'm most unhappy about, there's really two things.
Das ist die Hongkong-Geschichte.
The first one is, we didn't live up to the high standards that we really set for ourselves.
Ist klar.
And the second is, we failed in our purpose.
And for that, I am sorry and I accept accountability.
So what exactly...
Die mussten, da musste sowas kommen.
Da musste sowas kommen.
Die wurden so zugeflamed.
So what exactly is our purpose?
BlizzCon is demonstrating it, even as we speak.
We aspire to bring the world together in epic entertainment.
And I truly believe in the positive power of the community.
Also ich kann die Maus wegmachen, aber das Ding geht nicht zu da unten.
When we get it right, we create a common ground where the community comes together.
To compete, connect and play.
Irrespective of the things that divide us.
As an example, BlizzCon has people from 59 countries all around the world here at the show today.
That is amazing.
Ja, das hat aber mit der Sache nichts zu tun.
And that is the positive power of video games.
To transcend divisions that surround us.
And so much.
In so many of our places today.
We will do better going forward.
But our actions are going to matter more than any of these words.
As you walk around this weekend, I hope it's clear how committed we are to everyone's right to express themselves.
In all kinds of ways.
In all kinds of places.
I've actually seen and heard many of you expressing yourself this morning.
You use your vacation and your family time to be here in Anaheim with us.
And we are so grateful that you're here this weekend.
Our best moments are here in our shared passion for Blizzard games.
So once again, BlizzCon has brought us together.
And today you're going to see a lot of the hard work of the Blizzard team.
Hard work pays off.
Okay, das war eigentlich eine absolute Luftnummer von Ansage.
Ist Lautstärke okay?
Das war halt absolut nichts sagen im Endeffekt, ne?
Was ist mit den Castern?
Kommen die wieder?
Was ist mit dem Typ, dem sie das Preisgeld konfisziert haben?
Are you ready to start the countdown?
Let's do it!
Wisst ihr was?
Wenn die gesagt hätten, so nach dem Motto, sie entschuldigen sich bei dem Typ.
Für diese ganze Geschichte.
Okay, das hätte ich ja noch verstehen können.
Das wäre mal eine Aussage gewesen, aber das wäre jetzt einfach um heißen Brei rumgeredet, ja?
Preisgeld hat er schon, okay.
Ja, Actions hat man nicht gesehen.
Ach komm.
Das war halt ein Statement, weil die Leute so rumgeflamed haben.
Das ist aber kein Statement gewesen, wo man sagen könnte, oh, da hat er sich aber weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt.
Oh fuck.
Ich wundere mich gerade, warum sich mein Schreibtisch hoch und runter fährt.
Ich stehe mit dem Fuß auf meinem Höhenregler vom Schreibtisch.
Okay, Achtung Leute.
Auf geht's.
Das sieht nach Diablo aus.
Das sieht nach Tristram aus.
Vielleicht.
Oder auch nicht, dafür ist die Kirche ein bisschen klein.
STFU.
Und?
Ich meine, das könnte Diablo sein, aber irgendwie...
Are you out of your mind?
He's not going to make it.
Dann doch wieder nicht.
He has to.
Blessed Akarat, my eternal light protects me, my divine wisdom guides me.
Hey, look at me.
All the gold we want is right there.
No, I, I just came here for knowledge.
Now, breach the seal.
Get us through that door.
Big brain time.
They come by three's eye.
Way opened.
Blood show.
This doesn't make any sense.
Rib.
Blood, blood is the key.
Blood is the key!
What?
I will kill you!
Now, go!
Das ist der Typ auf Game of Thrones.
It has the blood of the willing.
Es hat schon ein bisschen was von Diablo, aber irgendwie so vom Style her noch so hundertprozentig.
Aber Diablo 4 halte ich für sehr wahrscheinlich.
Nein, er ist nicht tot.
Offensichtlich nicht.
But why?
Er lebt.
Ist er nicht mehr verbunden?
Kein Ehrenmann.
Und bei drei sie kommen, bei drei dein Weg öffnet sich, bei vielen von ihnen.
Willen.
Heil.
Heil der...
Der Schöpfer.
Heil die Tochter...
Oh nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Was ist mit der Karte?
Was sagt sie?
Das ist verboten.
Das ist eine Anzeige.
Ich kann nicht sprechen.
Du lügst mir nicht.
Wir sind hier für Treue.
Was ist das für ein Ort?
Ich...
Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht ist es ein Tempel.
Oder zwei mehr.
Aber so ganz passt es nicht, finde ich.
Ja gut, drei...
Ist das Baal oder wie soll das sein?
Eis.
Das Eterne Licht schützt mich.
Es ist ein...
Es ist kein Licht hier.
Du bist in die Dunkelheit gekommen.
Für Wissen.
Ah, ja, Wissen.
Oh, ja.
Er sagt doch noch jetzt.
Und all the knowledge you seek is here.
Surrender.
Speak the words.
Call her home.
By three they come.
By three thy way opens.
By the blood of the willing
we call thee home.
What?
A Trailer, können sie das?
Kann sie nichts sagen.
Nee, dann muss es doch Diablo sein.
Muss Diablo...
Sanctuary ist die Welt von Diablo.
Oder?
Was? Borderlands Crossover?
Ein Diablo-Grill!
Ja, das ist Diablo.
Jetzt ist klar.
Jawoll!
Jetzt! War klar.
War irgendwo was klar.
Die Crowd war auch schon mal gehypter.
Wobei man sagen muss...
Ganz ehrlich, bei Diablo 3 wäre ich auch nicht so gehypt gewesen.
Also jetzt nach Diablo 3.
Ejax, du hast nichts verpasst. Außer Diablo 4.
Gerade eben.
Good morning BlizzCon!
It is so very good to be here.
I wanna thank all of you for coming.
And a big thank you to Blizzard Cinematics
for starting things off for Diablo 3.
For starting things off the right way this weekend.
I know you all want to hear about the game.
So let's get to it.
Genau, jetzt kommt es mobile.
Diablo 4 is darkness.
World and legacy.
Let's start with darkness.
Diablo 4 is dark.
You just saw the cinematic, so you know exactly what I'm talking about.
Whether it's the art, the story, or the horror elements that we've embraced.
The first thing you will notice about Diablo 4...
Hörer, denk schon mal da dran.
...is that we are going back to the franchise's darker roots.
It will mean blood and gore.
It will mean occult symbols and rituals.
More importantly, it will mean victories are neither clean nor guaranteed.
We hope you're as excited about that as we are.
Ja, also ich bin erst excited, wenn ich das Game gesehen hab.
Then we have world, also super important for Diablo 4.
Because we've only seen glimpses into Sanctuary in previous Diablo games.
But those glimpses have enthralled us and captured our imaginations.
With Diablo 4 we want to put the world of Sanctuary front and center.
We want every character, every monster, every faction to have a sense of place.
Drowned undead that emerge from the coastlines.
Brutal goatmen that come from the hills above us.
Die armen Goatmen, ey.
And as we go deeper and deeper into the depths below...
Was ist es mit diesen komischen Ziegenmenschen,
die dieses Action-RPG hat?
Warum hat jedes Action-RPG Ziegenmenschen?
The world is also how you'll experience most of our game.
It is there that you will find enemy camps and friendly towns alike.
It is also where you'll find players to interact with.
Whether it's to trade with them, group with them,
or should you choose to do so, murder each other in PvP zones.
Naja, das hat ja schon in Diablo 3 gut funktioniert.
Besser gesagt gar nicht.
Finally, legacy.
Whether it's the sense of dread from Diablo 1,
or the classic class lineup and loot chase that we still are inspired by from Diablo 2,
or the best in class visceral and fluid combat from Diablo 3 that we still enjoy,
we are approaching this series with complete reverence.
We hope that it shows.
If you are new to the series,
we want you to feel like we did when we first played Diablo.
If you're a long time fan,
we think this is the game you've been waiting for.
Isometric Action-RPG,
developed for PC, PlayStation 4 and Xbox One.
Wow, but Path of Exile ist schwer zu übertreffen.
Guck mal, der hat Veganer!
Auf seinem Arm stehen.
A first glance at Diablo 4,
along with our first three classes.
The Barbarian,
the Sorceress,
and the Druid.
On behalf of everyone on the Diablo 4 team,
it is our absolute pleasure now
to share with you the world premiere
of the Diablo 4 gameplay trailer.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt. Zeigt mal her.
Huge gameplay.
The dream continues to haunt me, old friend.
It always starts with a journey
to a distant land.
Ah, yes.
There I find a city in flames.
Streets choked with corpses.
Unthinkable to name.
Executions.
Suffering surrounded me
until my turn comes
in terror.
There's no one left to stand against them.
Gut, das sieht jetzt nach nichts irgendwie
umwerfendem Neues aus bis jetzt,
aber das wusste Diablo auch nicht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, sie müssen schon irgendwas bieten,
weil Path of Exile ist...
Oh, ist das hier Druid? Ja, eindeutig.
Path of Exile ist mittlerweile
so ein komplexes,
vielfältiges Game,
schwierig dagegen anzukacken.
Oh, man kann jetzt klettern.
Sieht aus wie Dulliel aus Diablo 2.
Also die Partikel-Geschichten
teilweise finde ich ganz nett.
Wobei das Gameplay jetzt halt echt
nicht sonderlich inspiriert aussieht,
muss man ehrlich sagen.
You think me mad, old friend.
But I know these dreams.
They tell of the future.
Vielleicht ist das auch Diablo Mo...
äh, Diablo Mobile.
Vielleicht ist das auch Diablo Mobile
umgebaut zu einem PC-Diablo.
Der Typ auf der Erde, Beste.
Alright, how did you guys like that first look?
Naja...
Super vom Hocker gehauen hat's mich nicht.
We have panels where we're gonna go deeper
into the features, the systems,
the world, the art of Diablo 4.
Starting with an unveil panel
right after opening ceremony on this stage.
But that's not all.
The team's been working super hard on the game
and therefore we've been able to bring up
a little bit of that, a little taste for that.
That's right, we have a very early look,
a demo playable on the floor today, right now.
Okay, das ist ganz cool.
We hope you have as much fun playing it
as we did making it.
And once again, on behalf of the game team,
thank you all and see you in hell.
Okay, das war mal ein schöner Schlusssatz für Diablo.
Gut, ich muss sagen, der Hype...
Also, bei mir...
Game Director of World of Warcraft,
Oh, jetzt kommt ein neues WoW-Add-On.
Muss ein neues WoW-Add-On, es gibt immer neue WoW-Add-Ons.
Also, das hat mich jetzt nicht so vom Hocker gelassen,
muss ich sagen.
Ich meine, es ist cool, dass es Diablo 4 gibt,
dass es gecheckt haben, dass die Leute das wollen.
Aber...
Ah ja.
Moment, was hat das mit WoW zu tun?
Heroes of the Storm!
Legends of the Tavern!
Die Leute!
Heroes of Overwatch!
And soon, ready to battle the minions of hell in Diablo 4,
the brave souls of Sanctuary!
Soon.
Mal gucken, wann soon ist.
It feels really great to be able to say the words Diablo 4 out loud.
We use code names when we're working on the game
and we train ourselves not to reference the real name.
Oh.
So, when we're able to kind of come out and finally say Diablo 4,
it feels a bit wicked.
Diablo 4.
Die Leute haben schon gar keinen Bock mehr drauf, ey.
We've actually had Diablo 4 in development for some time.
You know, when we come before you,
we want to ensure that when we reveal Diablo to you,
that we can give you a good look at the dark vision of Sanctuary,
along with a playable experience here at BlizzCon.
You know, I personally spent a lot of time playing Diablo over the years
and a lot of love has gone into this game
and it really helped everyone.
You can talk about what else is here for us at BlizzCon,
our baker's dozen BlizzCon lucky number 13.
What?
We see BlizzCon as the place where the Blizzard community
can have a home away from home.
It's our home, too,
because many of us have grown up playing Blizzard games.
We've forged lifelong friendships.
We've made memories.
And we've also had a lot of fun over the last 28 years.
This year, for the very first time,
we've set up something to honor that legacy
and celebrate the beginning of what's made Blizzard great.
Celebrate the games and the communities
that we have.
We're excited to debut the Blizzard Arcade in Hall E.
The Blizzard Arcade has an old school arcade vibe.
Gather there with friends, play some games
and experience some of the earliest things
that Blizzard has ever made.
For the very first time at BlizzCon,
we have rock and roll racing,
Blackthorn,
and the Lost Vikings.
Who cares?
If you've never experienced these games before,
or if you have,
and you want to relive the magic,
then the Arcade is a great place to hang out.
Who cares?
Joey Ray's Bar,
as well as the Slaughtered Calf Inn are there,
so you're welcome to kick back, relax, and enjoy.
But the Arcade isn't just a celebration
of where we've come from.
It's also a showcase of some of our new announcements.
Let's talk about...
StarCraft 2.
Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt.
If you're a StarCraft fan,
we have two exciting things for you in the Arcade.
For several years, we've been working with Google
and the DeepMind Artificial Intelligence Project.
The DeepMind group has taught agents
how to play the game as part of their AI research.
And I'm excited to say that for the very first time,
players are going to be able to pit themselves
against DeepMind AI agents
right here on the show floor.
Das finde ich cool.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nichts,
was man eigentlich in einer Riesenpräsentation erzählen müsste,
aber das ist cool.
We have master-level agents.
We have a diamond-level agent.
And just a quick note that if you try this,
you will not win.
Three of you will win.
I won't win.
For StarCraft 2 fans,
we've also been really hard at work
on bringing an iconic villain
to life.
I'm excited to announce that the leader
of the Sons of Korhav
and the ruler of the Terran Dominion,
Arturus Manx,
is coming to the game later this month
as the next co-op commander.
Manx is unlike any commander that you've ever played,
and at BlizzCon,
he's loaded up and ready for you in the Arcade.
Let's talk Heroes of the Storm.
For Heroes fans,
the team has brought
Deathwing the Destroyer
into the Nexus.
Deathwing is actually
the most requested hero of all time,
and we're excited for you
to have an opportunity to play.
Deathwing actually has two forms
with two different sets of abilities,
bringing the iconic
Worldbreaker fantasy to life.
Deathwing is playable here
for the third time in the Blizzard Arcade.
And we're excited to announce
that the Deathwing
is now available
for everyone
who plays the game
in the Nexus.
Everyone with a BlizzCon
or virtual ticket
will automatically
receive Deathwing
when he enters the Nexus.
.
bisschen boosten jetzt das Ganze, ist ja okay. Ich wollte schon ewig mal wieder die Warcraft
3 Kampagne spielen. Ewig. Das werde ich machen, also das kaufe ich mir auf jeden Fall, wenn
ich rauskomme, nur um mal die Kampagne wieder zu spielen. Ja gut, lügt mich nicht. Wo
ihr ewig gebraucht habt für, ne?
Ist Barons Brachland?
Ich habe nie war gespielt, großartig.
Who cares? Das juckt mich, wow, Eiscreme.
Da haben wir schon mal wieder ein bisschen Overwatch geguckt, das war ganz nice.
Congratulations to the San Francisco Shock and 2019 MVP Sinatra. Next season, the league
is moving to a home and away format. And that means there is competition taking place in
20 cities all around the world.
Wow.
And this is the very first time that something like this has been done in esports.
Jeff, Jeff.
It is a great time to be a fan of the Overwatch League and it's a great time to love Overwatch.
Give Jeff Jeff.
At BlizzCon this weekend, the best of the best are gonna battle it out in the Overwatch
World Cup featuring more than 30 country based teams from all around the world.
We'll also be celebrating Champions and crowning Champions for Starcraft 2 World Championship
Series.
Oh Leute, zeigt halt was.
Der ist ein cooler Typ, den mag ich irgendwie, den Reinhard Sprecher.
Alright, in closing, I just want to say, there's a lot of people out there that are Blizzard employees and they're there in the crowd.
And the reason that all of us are here is you.
We're here to celebrate this moment with you.
You know, we really look forward to this weekend.
This is a highlight for us all year to come together and to celebrate all the passion of Blizzard Games.
And so, all of you watching, we are grateful.
Thank you for being here with us.
BlizzCon, be good to one another.
Welcome home.
Okay.
Es ist noch nicht fertig.
Es kann noch nicht fertig sein, weil es geht noch eine halbe Stunde.
Ah, jetzt kommen die einzelnen Sachen, genau.
Okay, es gibt, es muss ja eigentlich ein neues Waradon geben.
Nee, nee, das war's nicht.
I am so honored and humbled to be up here with all of you on behalf of World of Warcraft.
As it turns 50.
This is a game that's been at the center of my life for every one of those 15 years.
I think 15 years ago on this day, I think I was wandering around looking for stores that were still taking pre-orders.
Ja, die Augen sehen echt ein bisschen, entweder es erkältet oder hat sich vorher beruhigt.
I had the privilege of joining the development team to start to try to give back to this game and to this community that have given me so much.
And here in this 15th anniversary year.
It's been a great.
It's been a great year for World of Warcraft.
Just taking a look back, we kicked things off with the Battle of Dazar'alor, an alliance and horde going head to head in a raid zone for the very first time.
Moved beneath the waves.
Oh, in 2K19.
19.
In 2K19, ja.
We've seen the Kul Tiran join the alliance and the Zandalari trolls bolster the ranks of the horde.
And of course we have Mechadomes and Vulpera waiting in the wings to join them in our upcoming Visions of N'Zoth update.
And of course.
Just over two months ago, we launched this little game called World of Warcraft Classic.
And as Jay said, it's been incredible watching millions return to Azeroth as it stood before the Cataclysm.
Whether you are returning home to an old friend after a long time away or experiencing it for the very first time, it's been an incredible journey.
And here on the 15th year of World of Warcraft, this community stands in strong support for Warcraft.
Eigentlich muss man Nostalrius für feiern.
Dass das mit Warclassic offiziell geklappt hat.
Ohne Nostalrius hätte es Warclassic garantiert nicht gegeben.
Das war ein Free-Chart für Warclassic.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wovon er spricht, weil ich die War gespielt habe. Großartig.
Nee, Heinsenberg gab es noch nicht.
Eigentlich ist es voll grotesk, dass die Leute jubeln, weil Content freigeschaltet wird, der vor 15 Jahren freigeschaltet wurde.
Ja.
Killmoves haben sie nichts zugesagt zum Release-Datum.
So lange es nicht wish.com ist, ist es gar was.
Jawoll, ich darf mir nen in-game Baby-Alpaka kaufen.
So, if you thought that Dali and Dot were your best friends, wait til you meet Dari.
Das sieht mega hässlich aus.
Find nicht, dass das süß aussieht, das sieht irgendwie unförmig aus.
Back in Battle for Azeroth, the year is not quite over.
We have this 15th anniversary celebration, that's just around the corner, and I mean
just around the corner.
This coming Tuesday, November 5th, we will be enabling all of 15th anniversary celebrities
Wollt ihr keine aus neues WoW-Ärends zeigen?
Es gibt doch jedes Mal neue WoW-Ärends.
Das Lustige ist,
das Lustige ist,
jetzt kriegst du Classic Raid Experiences in Battle for Aetheros,
anstatt WoW Classic spielen zu können.
Das ist mal geil.
Hä?
What?
Es wäre geil, wenn ihr einfach mal geile Sachen celebratet.
Und dann gibt es das Wollko-Team.
Eine Vierteljahre, 15 Jahre mit WoW, 25 Jahre mit WoW
und die Besten, die noch vorliegen.
Dann zeigt mal, was das Beste wird.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Der Hype ist real. Das sieht man den zwei richtig an.
So wie lustig es in den letzten 15 Jahren war,
und dieses Jahr mit WoW war,
wissen wir alle, dass der besondereste Teil des WoW-Sortierens jedes Jahr
die dazu kommt, zu hören und zu sprechen, was Beruhen anbietet.
Ja. Ich spiele zwar keinen WoW, aber die Trailer gucke ich mir gerne an.
Und zweimal Exciting verpasst.
Die WoW-Lore ist eh komplett im Arsch.
Die ist null konsistent und wir ohne Ende.
Genau, macht WoW dicht. Ganz bestimmt.
Ich kann mir keine unbekannten, unbekannten Ende ansehen.
Oder jemanden, der in den Schatten fliegt, der für Revenge wartet.
Kannst du?
Oh, fuck. Ich hab recht.
Ich hab nie WoW gespielt und gleich mal hier predicted.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das geleakt war.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß nur, dass Ball war oder so.
Dieser, der Palla-Typ aus dem Raid.
Dass der jetzt der neue Lich King ist, seit Ende vom Elfjahr.
Weil ich ein bisschen WoW-Lore kenne.
Glaubt man erst mal, wer ist das Horde-Waifu?
Der ist er ja.
Stimmt, der ist ja, der ist ja, der fackelt ja, weil er von irgendwelchen Drachendingern angefackelt wurde, storytechnisch.
Weil WoW-Story und so.
Guck mal, der kann die Farbe wechseln.
Hat der RGB?
Volva RGB?
Gaming Edition?
Platinium?
Voll RGB-Rüstung, Daniel, genau.
Ich mein, Cinematics können sie echt.
Wäre Arthas damals so einfach zu bashen gewesen, ne?
Reckt.
Ja, wenn das so einfach mit dem Lich King ist.
Ja, das war mit Arthas auch so einfach gewesen.
Ehre genommen, ne?
This world is a prison.
Gibt es jetzt die Lich Queen?
Ah, ne.
Moment, müsste die nicht auch sterben, wenn der Lich King, Lich King nicht mehr Lich Kingt?
Müsste die nicht eigentlich auch, weil...
Will set us all free.
Ich mein, Cinematics können sie, da kannst du ja nix sagen, ne?
Hellolands, okay.
Aber müssten sie nicht eigentlich auch sterben, wenn der Lich King stirbt?
Weil, sie wurde doch in der Warcraft 3 Kampagne von Arthas quasi wieder als, als Untote erweckt.
Und ich dachte, dass alle Untote irgendwie sterben, wenn sie, wenn sie, wenn der Lich King tot ist.
Deswegen muss ja auch immer ein Lich King da sein.
So, yeah, that just happened.
Also, Wo-Lore, ja?
We were once told by King Taranis, that there must always be a Lich King.
And now, for the first time, there is none.
Sylvanas herself warned us, that in the end, death claims us all.
Well, death is coming for us.
And if we want to stand a chance, we are going to have to go where no living soul ever has.
We are going to the Shadowlands.
The world that is the afterlife for the entire Warcraft universe.
Now, along the way, we will get a chance to meet some of the fallen and learn their fates.
But this is not a familiar world, full of orcs and trolls and dwarves.
This is an ancient and mysterious realm that predates the titans themselves.
It is the source of the power of the Scourge that we have seen, true.
And it's the power upon which death knights draw.
But it's also the origin of the noble Valkyr.
And the spirit healers that guide us back to the land of the living, when we pull a couple mobs too many.
Not that anyone's ever done that.
It's where spirits of nature go to begin a cycle of rest and rebirth.
And so it was.
Let's take a look at this wondrous world that we are sent to as well.
The Jailer of the Damned.
A grim task.
Which I...
have failed.
Oh, the eternal veil screams.
Torn asunder.
I have...
within the realm of shadowlands.
Is the darkest of terrors.
Which should never be set free.
The shadowlands are infinite.
Their terrors and beauty were never meant for mortal eyes.
I wonder if they can bear to behold.
All that awaits them.
Spodas!
The denizens of this realm are the key to restoring the balance between life and death.
Damit kriegen sie ein paar mal Excited vergessen.
If their trust can be earned.
Ja, da sieht man viel mit dem Helm.
New Dungeons and Raids.
Da hätten wir nie von einem neuen Woe Addon erwartet, dass es neue Dungeons and Raids gibt.
Aber es kann was Neues.
Gut.
Ich denke, für Leute, die WoW spielen, ist das cool.
Ihr wisst, ich spiel kein WoW, deswegen kann ich schlecht einschätzen.
Aber ich denke für WoW, die Leute, die WoW spielen, ist das eine coole Sache.
The World of Warcraft Shadowlands is coming next year.
And it will be available for pre-purchase today.
There is just a little glimpse of this incredible world that awaits us.
Ahead of us lie many fateful decisions.
Because at its core, Shadowlands is a new world.
Because at its core, Shadowlands is an expansion that is built around the idea of choice.
Agency and self-expression.
In the rewards you pursue.
And in the allies with whom you cast your lot.
I know you have a ton of questions.
Like, what the heck is a covenant?
What is that tower that's sticking out of the sky above Icecrown?
What other changes are coming to World of Warcraft?
And so much more.
So, we have our first panel for you at 2.30 on the Mythic Stage.
The World of Warcraft.
What's next?
The panel.
We will dig into that.
And much, much more.
Also, playable here on the show floor, we invite you to journey into the zone of Bastion
and to begin to explore the Shadowlands.
Thank you all so much.
And it's going to be an incredible weekend ahead.
I can't wait to share it with all of you.
And now, it's my pleasure to turn things over to Ben Thompson on the Hearthstone team.
Esports.
Null.
Weg.
Leute, es ist E-Sport-Time.
Hearthstone ist am Start.
What's up, BlizzCon?
So thrilling to be here with you today.
Ah, thrilling zählt auch.
Holy cow level.
That Diablo announcement.
War das schlecht.
And World of Warcraft Shadowlands.
Aber eigentlich war der Witz schon wieder gut, ey.
I am so excited for what we are showing you here today.
I don't know about you, but I cannot wait to play some games.
Can you?
Look, whether it's demons crawling out of the very bowels of hell
or the skies above us shattering to pieces,
it is clear that Blizzard loves telling you a good story.
Sometimes we feel, however, that you shouldn't have to leave the safety of the tavern
to enjoy a good tale.
We believe some of the best stories are told right here at home.
Take, for instance, the story that we've been telling you this year,
in the Year of the Dragon.
For the very first time, we've introduced you to a story
that is taking all three sets to tell.
It is so big and so awesome.
Awesome.
We have been having a lot of fun putting it together.
We cannot wait to show you how it all comes to an end.
But let's talk a little bit about how it all began.
The Rise of Shadows, you were introduced to the formation of a league of evil.
Their plot to steal Dallon and just how you helped them do it.
This was followed by the saviors of all doom,
as you and the League of Explorers answered the call to adventure
and crossed the desert sand,
seeking to wipe out the plagues that Rafaam and his followers had set loose upon the world.
Well, that brings us to the final chapter of this time.
The curtain rises on a shimmering twilight sky across a blanket of snow.
A chill wind gusts across an ancient field of bones.
Now the League of Evil and the League of Explorers,
well, they've chased each other across all of Azeroth
to arrive here in Dragonblight.
Ach so, ja.
Was ist, wenn ich die Bildschirme switche?
Dann geht die Maus automatisch in die Mitte. Das sagt ein bisschen.
Oh ne, stimmt, bei Hearthstone singen sie ja immer.
All heroes can't fly.
They fall like shooting stars.
Will anyone survive?
Slide above the ice and snow, high in the sky with a cold and low.
Weak feet down to defect bones.
The good unites against people they oppose.
They ride and die, it's a chiller.
Rhymes and sets get the killer.
They go round and round and round.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Disney-Filmen.
Die sind ja auch ganz nett.
Bis auf die Part, wo gesungen wird.
The year of the dragon is gonna finally earn its name
with more dragons in a single Hearthstone expansion than ever before.
Now you're gonna recognize quite a number of these from Azeroth's storied history,
but we've stuck a couple in there of our own devising as well for you to enjoy.
Descent of Dragons also introduces a handful of new mechanics
and one all-powerful new keyword as well.
You wanna dive in and take a look?
Let's do it!
Now it wouldn't be right to make a set based around dragons
without at least acknowledging the most terrible,
the most feared and fearsome dragon ever to walk the world of Azeroth.
No, not Deathwing.
It's the progenitor of all dragonkind, the fearsome Galakrond.
Yeah?
Galakrond is Hearthstone's newest hero card.
That is to say, he takes the place of your own hero when you put him into play.
He also brings with him a powerful new battlecry and his own unique hero power.
But here's the key. He becomes stronger, more powerful,
when you make use of our newest keyword, Invoke.
Invoke.
More randomness!
Goal!
Whether he be in your hand or in your deck.
And by doing so, you will allow him to achieve his second form.
Gets a bit stronger.
Now believe it or not, there are actually those who eagerly await Galakrond's return.
He can't praise his name across Azeroth.
And as a result, the Invoke keyword will occasionally show up on some neutral cards as well.
Doing so will allow you to achieve the most feared and third final form of Galakrond.
That of...
Galakrond, Azeroth's End.
Kreativer Name.
I don't know if this actually signals the end of all of Azeroth.
Frankly, from what we've just seen, I'm pretty sure that's Sylvanas' job now.
But it sure as heck signals the end of any game of Hearthstone he's in,
if you can appropriately pull off the Invoke mechanic.
All five classes aligned with the League of Evil
will have access to the terrible power of Galakrond
and be able to harness it for themselves
in the form of a unique hero, bringing a unique battlecry
and a one-of-a-kind hero power as well.
Now Rafaam, he takes care of his friends.
He is assured that everyone will receive a copy
of all five Galakrond legendary hero cards for free.
Just for logging into the set line.
But you may ask, what of the just and noble?
What of those pure of heart?
Or more on the side of good?
Where are my League of Explorers in this?
Well, there are plenty of our winged friends
eager to join the fight for good as well.
You all know you, Sarah.
Let's say hello to the druid legendary dragon,
Ysera Unleashed.
She is my favorite too.
And finally, what would a dragon be
without their fearsome breath weapon?
If you're a shaman, you're gonna have access
to lightning breath here.
Yeah, we see all our dragon priest friends out there.
You look like you're having a good time.
We just think it's time to open up the party a little bit.
You see, with every class in Hearthstone,
we'll receive a legendary dragon.
Excellent.
Ah, yes.
We're sure to see their presence being made known in the meta
as soon as we release this newest and final chapter
to the trilogy on December 10th.
Ich kann dazu halt absolut nichts sagen.
Oh, guck mal.
Ein Pachamari-Cosplay, oder wie die Dinger heißen in Overwatch.
Pachimari?
Pachamari?
Now normally that'd be it for Hearthstone.
I've given you an amazing new set,
an awesome new cinematic,
and a song that I know I'm gonna be humming
for the rest of the weekend.
But we're not done.
We wanna leave you with something a little special
before we go.
As Hearthstone players ourselves,
we all continue to enjoy a variety
of ways to play this game we know and love.
Whether it be in the arena mode,
or Tavern Brawl mode,
we enjoy thinking of the cards
we build and craft and play.
And the decks that we put them in
in different ways.
That's why the Hearthstone team is excited
to announce today an entirely new way
to play this game.
And it's a new mode
that we like to call
Hearthstone Battlegrounds.
Oh.
Hearthstone Battlegrounds
is an eight-player mode
that is inspired...
all eight.
Eight-player mode that is inspired
by the popular auto-battler genre
with a few Hearthstone twists.
In this mode,
you and seven other players
are challenged to recruit minions
and send them into battle
against your opponents
until only one victor remains.
This is the first new mode
to come to the game in some time.
We had so much fun making this,
we had even more fun playing it.
So much so, in fact,
that we are excited to dedicate
the entirety of the Hearthstone demo area
here at BlizzCon to Battlegrounds
over the next two days.
And a Hearthstone auto-battler.
And that at a time when auto-battler
are already almost out.
The open day for this new mode
is going to start on November 12th.
But for those of you here today
watching at home with the virtual computer
or pre-purchasing Descent of Dragons,
well, you're going to get to enjoy
this all starting on Tuesday.
We couldn't be more excited
to announce even more
and talk about more cards
and things related to Descent of Dragons
and Hearthstone Battlegrounds
on the Mythic Stage at 3.30.
We look forward to seeing you all there.
From the very beginning,
Hearthstone was always intended
to be a warm and welcoming place.
It's a place and a home
far away from a confusing
and frustrating world
outside the Tavern.
It's a place to set down our swords,
join our friends
and gather around the fire.
With the return of the Hearthstone Tavern
here at BlizzCon,
we hope you do just this.
We absolutely invite you to come by
and tell us what you think of the new mode.
And we love answering questions
about the newest set.
But mostly, we hope you just drop by.
If only to take part in the warm,
and the friendship
that the Tavern has to offer.
I know I'll be there,
and I look forward to seeing each and every one of you.
I don't know about you guys,
but I really need to see
what Overwatch has to offer.
Let's go take a look, shall we?
30 years ago,
the Omnics declared war.
Overwatch was created
to rescue humanity
from the Omnic Crisis.
They became the greatest champions
of peace and progress
mankind has ever seen.
Peanut butter?
Everybody knows
Overwatch got shut down.
Half of them are just mercenaries now.
The people decided
they were better off without us.
They even called us criminals.
They tore our family apart.
Papa told me
after so many years of service
you gave Overwatch everything.
And they pushed you out.
Real life is not like
the stories our father told us.
You were a fool for believing it so.
Perhaps I am a fool
to think there is still hope for you.
Brother.
Human.
Machine.
Before we ask you the future,
humans and Omnics
standing together.
The second Omnic Crisis
continues.
The conflict between Omnics and humans
has claimed over 50,000 lives.
Come out.
Someone has to do something.
We have to do something.
Always remember.
Never accept the world
as it appears to be.
Dare to see it
for what it could be.
Winston?
It's been too long.
What is this?
We are broadcasting on the
overwatching news frequency.
I got a call.
I want me.
But really, I need you.
I feel so cold.
I must answer.
The enemy around him
is getting stronger.
The world is changing once again
and it's time to pick a side.
We can make
a difference again.
The world needs us now.
More than ever
Are you with me?
Yes, Winston.
Mace to the face.
I am with you.
Brigitte is my favourite
Overwatch-Girl.
Oh!
Jeff, Jeff.
Please welcome
Game Director of Overwatch
Jeff Kaplan.
How are you all doing?
You having fun?
No, they are just happy
that he is on the stage.
I wore black.
It's kind of like
dad-edgy
because it's got a giant pink bunny on it.
I didn't quite get there.
So I feel like you and I
and you know who I'm talking to
I feel like you and I
have been together for a very long time.
Like
we remember
when WoW Classic
used to be called
WoW.
We've been around together.
I have something
Don't ever say that.
that I'm very embarrassed to tell you now
and I'm only telling you
because we have this close relationship.
I totally forget what I'm supposed to say right now.
I don't have a clue.
Just drew a blank.
Anybody who knows me knows
I can just ramble forever about anything.
But luckily
I can
from the internet
read everything
I'm supposed to say
from the last week.
Thank you
so much for helping me with that.
Oh my gosh.
That was so sweet.
The team really appreciated it.
Actually, if you want to know how game developers
feel about
leaks.
The WoW team made a cinematic
called Shadowlands
and picture my face
where Sylvanas's was
and then instead of that helmet
it was my cell phone.
And that, yeah.
I should probably
talk about Overwatch now.
I'm just digging a hole, you know.
So,
a very dear friend of mine
five years ago
on this stage
almost to this very day
a gentleman by the name of
Chris Metzen
and let him hear it.
He's watching with us right now.
Chris,
Chris came out five years ago
on this stage
and he said it's time
for a new adventure
and he wanted to take us all
with him
and he came out
and he announced Overwatch
and it was one of the most special moments
of my life
and the women and men
who work on Overwatch
have been working so hard
to make something very special
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es Overwatch 2 heißt, aber es wird wahrscheinlich...
Ich denke mal, das ist ein Add-on.
Moment Leute, ich mache schnell den Chat aus.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Das gibt sowas wie Chapter 2.
Genau, sag ich ja.
Das gibt kein Overwatch 2.
Ich denke auch, dass es sowas wie Chapter 2 gibt.
Dick.
André sagt, er hat auch Flugzeuge.
Wobei, ich kann die wirklich...
Die war ja in der Story, glaube ich, sogar Testpilot früher.
Overwatch Lore in 2019.
Jawohl, reinhüpfen und tasern.
Ah, yes.
Forget.
Das ist so cool gemacht.
Oh, huge Omnic.
Kommt ein französischer Held?
Da wurde Winston in zwei Hälften gelasert.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Mercy?
Tracer, get everyone out of here.
I'll hold the line.
But, you said to stick together.
Don't worry.
I'll be right behind you.
You'd better be.
Winston macht keinen Scheiß.
Setz mal ein Schild, Winston, Alter.
Drück mal E.
Drück E.
Oder macht...
Oder drück Q.
Drück Q.
Irgendwas.
Oh, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt Genji-Stells erstmal.
So einfach mal Parry gedrückt.
Eats Win Eats Life.
Mach ich nicht.
Ich habe E-Drop.
Oh, das war ein cooles
Intro.
Mace to the face
ist auch am Start.
Kommt jetzt Mercy?
Oh, es lasert immer noch.
Oh, Double Shield-Meta.
Es ist offiziell, Leute. Es geht weiter.
Bam.
Direkt.
Noch mal ein cooler Trailer.
Victory is ours, my friends.
Hi, Lena. Brigitte?
Oh my gosh, you've grown.
Oh, everyone.
This is Mei. Hi, everyone.
Nice to meet you.
Monsieur, does this mean
Overwatch is back?
Yes.
Yes, we are.
Oh.
Das ist trotzdem
Chapter 2.
Das ist trotzdem Chapter 2.
Wartet mal ab.
Wartet mal ab, was die mit dem Original-Game machen.
Das ist Chapter 2. Das ist nicht Overwatch 2.
Ich kann wetten.
Did you enjoy it?
Awesome.
On behalf of the
Overwatch team, I am
extremely proud and excited
to finally and
officially announce
Overwatch 2.
Okay, es ist wirklich Overwatch 2. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Now I know you have
a lot of questions.
But we always feel like our games
speak for themselves, so let's take
a look at the gameplay and then we'll talk.
Jawoll, Chef. Zeig her.
Jetzt mit PVE.
Oh, der Beat wird
gedroppt, Leute.
What are you doing here?
It's happening again.
Paris was just the beginning.
This is a global invasion.
So, how's Overwatch
enjoyed our city?
Ja, PVE?
Sag mal, ist Reinhardt noch älter geworden?
One day.
It has been too long, Master.
I can't do this.
You've made your choice.
Nobody will stop us.
Trouble is cropping up all over the world.
It's not just
an old sector.
A lot of lives are riding on what we do next.
We'll have to fight.
One city at a time.
Let's get them, Brigitte!
Ark, word.
Work.
Endlich.
Oh, das ist nice.
Level.
Ich wusste, dass...
Ja.
Ja, das war klar.
Das ist eine richtig gute Sache.
Dass Helden Variable Fähigkeiten kriegen.
Aber Leute,
guckt euch an, es sind die gleichen Maps,
die gleichen Helden.
Ich sage immer noch, dass es sowas wie Season 2 ist.
Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Wusste ihr eigentlich, dass Lucio
ursprünglich ein Hockeyspieler sein sollte aus Kanada?
Sojourn hier.
Oh, wer ist das?
Das Interface
sieht ein bisschen anders aus als am Anfang.
Es sieht besser aus.
Aber nicht...
Also es ist immer noch ein Deutsch Overwatch.
Oh, wir werden so viel Spaß haben.
Es wird so toll sein.
Gleiche Lenden, gleiche Maps.
Das ist Season 2.
Wir haben viel zu sprechen, oder?
Zunächst und vor allem
müssen wir uns erinnern,
dass Overwatch
Overwatch ist eine Team-versus-Team-6v6-Kompetitiv-Erfahrung und es gibt keinen Weg, das zu verlieren.
Das ist ein großer Fokus.
Overwatch 2 wird eine neue, Core-Kompetitiv-Game-Mode namens Push haben.
Was ich meine, wenn ich Core sage, ist, dass du es in Quickplay spielst, es wird in Kompetitiv gespielt
und es wird auch in der Overwatch League gespielt.
Wir sind sehr gespannt darauf, endlich eine neue, Core-Kompetitiv-Game-Mode hinzuzufügen.
Wir wollen, dass alle hier heute die Chance haben, sie zu spielen und uns zu erzählen, wie großartig und balanceiert sie ist.
Ihr könnt also auf einer ganz neuen Karte spielen, die in Toronto stattfindet.
Unsere erste kanadische Karte.
Sie ist in Hall A.
Wir bitten euch, die Demo zu spielen.
Wir glauben, ihr werdet großartig sein.
Als ich mit vielen von euch gesprochen habe,
ist es eine gemeinsame Anmerkung, die ihr aus Overwatch wollen wollt.
Und Overwatch 2 wird das erreichen.
Und das ist für mehr Geschichte und für PvE.
Für kooperative Erfahrungen.
Overwatch 2 wird viel PvE-Kontent veröffentlichen.
Wir werden eine komplette Geschichte-Erfahrung haben,
die Geschichte-Missionen veröffentlichen,
die erste davon, die Rio de Janeiro heißt,
wird auch in Hall A für euch heute spielbar sein.
Rio ohne Lucio geht ja nicht.
Außerdem, wie ihr gesehen habt,
haben wir etwas, was wir als Hero-Missionen nennen.
Die Hero-Missionen fokussieren sich darauf,
auf eine hochspielbare, kooperative Erfahrung zu spielen.
Die Analyse, die wir auf unserem Team verwenden,
ist ähnlich wie die Adventure-Mode für Diablo
gegen seine Kampagne.
Das ist, was die Hero-Missionen geplant sind.
Und sie werden durch dieses coole Progression-System gefördert,
wo ihr eure Helden leveln könnt,
stärker werden, eure Fähigkeiten customisieren,
verschiedene Talente machen.
Es wird viel Spaß geben.
Ihr habt vielleicht auch bemerkt,
dass die Helden alle einen neuen Blick auf sie haben.
Jeder von den 31 Helden plus mehr
bekommt einen neuen Blick auf sie.
Und es gibt ein wirklich tolles Panel,
das morgen, am Donnerstag, in hier stattfindet,
das durch all die Engine-Upgrades durchführt,
zu Overwatch 2 kommt.
Und all die neuen Ausgaben und Erklärungen
des neuen Art-Stiles,
über die ich sehr gespannt bin.
Jetzt, Overwatch und Overwatch 2
sind an ihrer Körperschaft alles über Helden.
Und wir wissen, dass wir kein neues Overwatch-Spiel
machen können, ohne neue Helden zu haben.
Also, Overwatch 2,
in Angelegenheit von Sojourn,
über die wir heute nicht sprechen,
außer nur zu bestätigen,
dass sie hier ist,
wird Overwatch 2 mehrere neue Helden
mit dem Spiel anbieten.
Und wir sind sehr gespannt darauf.
Nun, viele von euch haben Fragen,
wie ein Sequel ist.
Oder was bedeutet das für mich,
als Spieler des originalen Spiels?
Ich habe so viel Zeit in dieses Spiel gespart.
Ich habe so viel Glauben darüber.
Nun, wir haben darüber nachgedacht.
Und für uns als Spieler,
wissen Sie, dass Sequeln uns nervös machen,
mehr als alles andere.
Also, was wir mit Overwatch 2 hoffen,
ist es wirklich,
was ein Sequel bedeutet.
Und ich denke,
es gibt jetzt eine richtige Erklärung.
Also, für alle originalen Spieler von Overwatch,
Spieler des aktuellen Overwatch-Spiels,
ihr werdet alle gleichen Maps spielen,
wie Overwatch 2-Spieler,
insbesondere alle neuen Maps,
die zu Overwatch 2 kommen.
Und ihr werdet alle gleichen Helden spielen,
wie Overwatch 2-Spieler.
Es wird ein gemeinsames Multiplayer-Bereich sein,
in dem niemand hinter sich bleibt.
Das andere,
über das viele von uns nachdenken,
ist all diese coolen Erfolge
und Kosmetik,
die wir in den letzten Jahren entdeckt haben.
Wie hart habt ihr gearbeitet
für eure Witch-Mercy-Skin?
Zum Beispiel.
Wir wollen sicher machen,
dass alle Overwatch-Kosmetik
mit euch in Overwatch 2 weiterkommt.
Also, all eure Prozesse sind wichtig.
Nichts bleibt hinter sich.
Niemand bleibt hinter sich.
Wir haben es so hart gemacht,
diese Community zu bauen,
von über 50 Millionen Spielern.
Das letzte, was wir tun würden,
wäre, etwas zu machen,
was eine großartige Community ihr seid.
Und wie viel ihr für uns bedeutet.
Also, Overwatch 2 wird großartig werden.
Wir haben ein Panel,
hier an dieser Stelle,
um 1.30 Uhr,
wo wir viel mehr Details machen werden.
Nun,
es ist Zeit für BlizzCon.
Ich stehe,
direkt über die Eile,
auf diese wunderschönen Maschinen,
mit Diablo 4 verpackt.
Wir haben World of Warcraft Shadowlands,
wir haben Hearthstone Battlegrounds.
Wir haben zwei verschiedene
Overwatch 2-Demos.
Ich möchte euch alle daran erinnern,
wie viel wir uns für einander bedeuten.
Seid gut für einander,
genießt euch dieses Wochenende.
Nun, lasst uns ein paar Videospiele spielen.
Habt Spaß, alle!
Oder Stormwind.
Oder ist es Stormwind?
Cool!
Nice!
Aber wie ich's...
Also Leute, ganz ehrlich,
die können das nennen, wie sie wollen.
Das ist im Endeffekt,
sowas wie Season 2.
Du kaufst die Grafik,
du kaufst die Koop-Missionen
und die Hero-Missions
und vielleicht auch Singleplayer-Content
und die neue Grafik.
Multiplayer wird wahrscheinlich das Gleiche sein.
Trotzdem, jeder, der ernsthaft Overwatch spielt,
wird sich natürlich den Zweier holen, ja.
Es gibt neuen Spielmodi, okay.
Die Sache ist bloß die...
Also übrigens,
muss ich mal sagen,
was ich richtig cool finde,
ist, dass du Sachen anlocken kannst bei Helden,
weil ich finde,
eines der Hauptprobleme, die Overwatch hat,
ist, dass es...
Es hat zwar relativ viele Helden mittlerweile,
aber es hat immer noch zu wenig Helden,
wenn man das mal mit irgendeinem MOBA oder so vergleicht.
Es hat zu selben Patches
und die Helden sind,
sind auch irgendwie zu...
zu gleich immer, ja.
Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen,
ich will den Held in dieser Composition spielen,
aber ein bisschen anders variiert.
Gibt's halt nicht.
Das mit den Skill-Trees finde ich cool.
Mehr Helden,
das Ding braucht unbedingt mehr Helden
und eigentlich braucht das Ding auch unbedingt
viel öfters Patches.
Liviosa, so verstehe ich das.
Du kannst, wenn du Multiplayer spielst,
spielst du Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2
exakt das gleiche.
Du bekommst in Overwatch 2
nur zusätzliche
Koop-Missionen und neue Grafik,
die du nicht in Overwatch 1
haben spielen kannst.
Also für mich sieht's so aus, als ist
im Prinzip
der reine Competitive-Multiplayer-
Aspekt kompatibel miteinander.
Die haben ja auch gesagt,
es ist Shared.
Und es ist im Endeffekt,
im Endeffekt ist es Overwatch Season 2.
Ich dachte nur für den PvE-Modus.
Ich hoffe auch mal für den Multiplayer.
Weil die Meinung zu Diablo 4
sieht irgendwie ziemlich,
keine Ahnung,
irgendwie, weiß nicht,
so ein bisschen uninspiriert aus.
Aber Overwatch 2 freut mich.
Overwatch 2 ist echt nice.
Danke für die ganzen Subs übrigens,
Leute, also den haben wir hier.
Trasterus, Neon Crusher,
GCAR,
SVW Paddy,
Boris1610
für 4 Monate.
Sebaro, 4 Monate resubscribed.
Dankeschön.
DaubyDay, resub 3 Monate.
Supports
für 2 Monate.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Huge Sub, Leute.
Mutiert, Stufe 1,
auch 4 Monate.
Nice.
Die könnten jetzt einfach,
wenn die den neuen
Competitive-Modus in Overwatch haben,
sie könnten
einfach 2CP
rauswerfen.
Weil 2CP hat die
beschissensten Maps
und den beschissensten Spielmodus.
Die sollen einfach 2CP
rauswerfen. Ich glaube, es gibt kaum einen,
der 2CP nachweinen würde.
2CP out.
Get out, 2CP.
Ja, Leute, was sagt ihr?
Was sagt ihr? Also ich muss sagen,
es war definitiv um
300% besser, mindestens mal,
als das letzte Jahr.
Viel besser als das letzte Jahr.
Letztes Jahr war ja einfach nur Crap.
Der ultra
krasse Hype bleibt bei mir
aus, aber es war schon ganz cool. Also Overwatch
2 finde ich eine coole Sache, auch wie sie das machen.
Wie gesagt, ES Season 2.
Diablo 4 mal gucken.
Wie gesagt, für mich ist Path of Exile immer noch
das beste Action-RPG, was es zurzeit gibt.
Und zu der ganzen WoW-Geschichte
kann ich nichts sagen, außer, dass es
in WoW-Trailer halt immer cool sind.
Was ist eigentlich aus Diablo Immortal geworden?
Juckt keinen mehr, oder?
Immortal ist Mortal,
ja, das ist weg.
Wie einfach alles geleakt wurde, ja.
Ich fand, es klang auch sehr plausibel, was sie
am Anfang erzählt haben zu Overwatch 2.
Weil im Endeffekt,
bloß die Free-to-Play-Geschichte wurde nicht
bestätigt.
Gingen ja auch die Gerüchte um, dass es Free-to-Play wird.
Habe ich ehrlich gesagt mit gerechnet,
ja.
Ich dachte mir, die bringen Season 2 raus,
machen das Base-Game irgendwie Free-to-Play
oder irgendwie sowas.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, die Ranked-Queues,
wenn man sich das so anguckt, das ist teilweise schon
krass lang. Fangen mit WoW an, ne.
Bloß nicht, dann mache ich ja keine Videos
mehr und keine Streams mehr.
Wenn ich MMOs spiele, dann immer richtig.
Ja gut, Hearthstone stimmt, aber
Hearthstone hat mich auch nicht gejuckt.
Die Skills anpassen
kann man nur im PvE? Da habe ich nicht so genau
hingehört. Ich hoffe, dass es auch im Multiplayer
ist, aber das würde ein bisschen mehr
Varianz geben, was Overwatch echt dringend
braucht. Ja,
das Buttertoss, so habe ich das auch verstanden.
Singleplayer und Koop und
Hero-Missions und bessere Grafik
kommen nur für Overwatch 2.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, man muss eh warten,
ähm,
bis sie überhaupt mehr zeigen, also
so wirklich,
so hundertprozentig schlau wird man da nicht
dabei. Die zeigen auf den
Panels mehr, ja, aber ich würde mir dafür kein
Ticket kaufen, ich warte einfach ab.
Ist ja nicht so, dass ich das jetzt eine Stunde
vor allen wissen muss, danach
kommt das ja eh alles raus.
Irgendwie haben die jetzt für mich jetzt drei Addons
vorgestellt, aber keine neuen Spiele.
Naja, Gott, Diablo 4 ist ein neues
Game, wobei ich mir halt nicht sicher bin, ob sie nicht
Immortal genommen haben und daraus
Diablo 4 gestrickt haben, keine Ahnung, wie das da
gelaufen ist. Ähm,
ja, aber das
eine Sache stimmt schon, so den richtig
großen neuen Hammer, den
gab's nicht. Nekorok,
vier Monate.
Samus Climber!
Samus Climber, nice!
Oje, Sebarro, das ist ein
großes Thema.
Fuck, Alter.
Es war ein bisschen
viel Cool Story Bro dabei, bei der
ganzen Geschichte. Das hätten die eigentlich
in 40 Minuten, 45 Minuten, hätten sie
das abfackeln können. Ich hab eineinhalb
Stunden gebraucht. Aber
okay. Äh,
Warcraft Reforged, gibt's,
läuft grad die Alpha, es scheint noch
ziemlich schlecht zu laufen, hab ich bei Krabby im
Stream gesehen.
Aber, ich werd auf jeden Fall die Kampagne nochmal
spielen von Warcraft 3.
Wollt ich schon immer mal spielen.
Das ist, da hab ich echt mal wieder Bock
drauf. Ja,
Bioware, da muss man, muss man gucken. Ich mein,
ich persönlich, nach
der ganzen Diablo 3 Geschichte und nach dem,
wenn ich, also wenn ich wirklich so nen,
so nen Hardcore Crying Loot Action
RPG spielen möchte, dann würde
ich eindeutig Path of Exile spielen und nicht
Diablo aktuell. Ähm,
ich bin mal gespannt, was sie
machen wollen mit Diablo 4,
dass sich das lohnt.
Jetzt noch mal von vorne los jetzt.
Och, ne.
Hab ich ein Ticket oder so? Warum kann ich das
gucken? Ich hab kein Ticket.
Ich glaub, die haben's einfach noch nicht ausgeschaltet.
Ob die Rank lassen, wie
es ist, ich fürchte,
ich fürchte, ja.
Ähm, allerdings
ist, ist das Problem, dass Ranked
Overwatch halt einfach so Hardcore suckt,
dass der, die müssen da eigentlich irgendwie
was machen. Also, wenn sie, wenn sie das so lassen,
dann ist das komplett für'n Arsch.
Overwatch World Cup is live.
Cool. Was kommt denn für'n Match jetzt?
Ah, erst mal
Woodface und Reinforced am Start.
Virtual Ticket only.
Path of Exile ist
gar nicht so hässlich. Hast du jemand, also
Diablo 4 sah jetzt auch nicht nach der Augenweite
von Game aus. Ja, alles
vorher geleakt.
Was müssen die nach meiner Meinung nach verändern? Boah.
Da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich muss mich über WoW Ranked noch, äh, über, über
Overwatch Ranked noch großartig auszulassen. Das hab ich schon
so oft gemacht. Außerdem muss ich
mich dann immer wieder reinversetzen ins Overwatch
spielen, wo ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf hab.
Hauptsächlich müssen sie eigentlich dafür sorgen,
dass du irgendwie ne, äh,
dass du, dass du mehr,
dass du
das Gefühl hast, mehr Einfluss
auf das, auf die Spiele zu haben.
Das ist das Hauptproblem an Overwatch Ranked.
Dass du, dass du,
dass du dich so hilflos fühlst.
Akira89,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Diablo 4 Grafik sieht aus, als wäre es auf dem Handy spielbar.
Ja, ich hab ja die Vermutung, die haben
im, im, im, Immobile, im, im
Immortal genommen und haben da
Diablo 4 draus gestrickt.
Find ich, sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Prediction. Was hätte dich
komplett aus den Socken gehauen, auch wenn es unrealistisch wäre?
Das Problem ist, das kann man ja schlecht
sagen, weil die Sachen, die dich aus den Socken
hauen, sind überraschend. Und überraschend
wär jetzt halt was, wo ich nicht dran gedacht hätte.
Zum Beispiel, wenn
Blizzard ein neues MMO angekündigt hätte.
Keine Ahnung, ein
Diablo MMO oder so, oder
was auch immer. Irgendwie sowas.
Das hätte mich voll aus den Socken gehauen.
Overwatch MMO, keine Ahnung.
Was weiß ich, wenn die zum Beispiel ein neues MMO
angekündigt hätte. Das hätte mich aus den Socken gehauen. Oder wenn die
Keine Ahnung, mir fällt
jetzt nichts ein, weil ich mein, das ist schwierig.
Sobald es mir einfällt, würde es mich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so richtig aus den Socken
hauen. Denn,
keine Ahnung, ein Overwatch Call of Duty
Crossover hätte mich aus den
Socken gehauen. Ich weiß allerdings nicht,
ob im positiven Sinne.
Da weiß ich ja.
Ja, ein Singleplayer
Storygame. Ein Singleplayer Storygame.
Fände ich auch mal wieder cool.
Irgendwas. Da hätte
mich einiges aus den Socken hauen können, aber
also hundertprozentig
aus den Socken hat mich nichts gehauen. Ich muss aber sagen, es war
viel besser als letztes Jahr. Overwatch war
cool, ähm
Diablo 4, mal gucken.
Aber Overwatch war auf jeden Fall nice.
Ansonsten
ist da halt immer viel heiße Luft bei, ne.
Okay, Leute.
Was war das?
Bits. Ein
Bit. Huge. Ein Cent
von einem Gaming Warlord.
Huge Donation.
Bitte ein Bit, ja.
In Reforged läuft
ja gerade die Alpha. Kann ja mal allzu lange dauern.
Sie haben gesagt, bis Ende des Jahres
habe ich irgendwo gelesen, bis Ende des Jahres
kommt
Reforged. Ja, Evoli, da muss
ich dir recht geben. Das machen die nicht, weil sie
ihre Spieler so geil finden, sondern einfach, weil die Leute
halt sehr an Overwatch 1 hängen und
es halt mit, sagen wir mal so, mit
im Prinzip dem gleichen Spiel
mit ein bisschen geupdater Grafik und Singleplayer
Mission jetzt nicht unbedingt die Leute da
dahinter am Montag vorlocken wird,
sich Overwatch 2 zu kaufen. Wenn man das so
macht, wie sie es jetzt machen, ist es natürlich
richtig, richtig clever. Dann haben nämlich
auch die Overwatch 2 Spieler auf jeden Fall was, mit
denen sie spielen können. Nein, spielerisch
ändert sich überhaupt nichts an Warcraft 3
mit Reforged. Gar nichts.
Die Engine ist exakt die gleiche darunter und das
muss auch so sein. Was meint ihr, was
los wäre, wie sehr die ganzen
Warcraft 3 Kenner und Ex-Pros
und Pros rumschreien würden, wenn die
wirklich was an der Engine ändern würden?
Dann könntest du die Einheiten überhaupt nicht mehr richtig
steuern, du könntest dich nicht mehr richtig surrounden
im Multiplayer. Also die
Engine bleibt genau die gleiche, die machen einfach nur ein bisschen
neue, höher auflösende
Models und Apps und Grafik und sowas.
Die ganzen Modmaps sollen
funktionieren. Da müssen ja, müssen ja,
weil es ist ja sogar Crossplay
Reforged. Also du kannst Reforged
kannst du ja Crossplay spielen mit
Warcraft 3 Classic.
Freust du dich eigentlich auf Halo
für einen PC?
Geht so. Weiß ich gar nicht,
ehrlich gesagt, ob ich mir das hole. Ich habe den ganzen
Kram gespielt, der mich bis
zum vorletzten Halo, das letzte hat mich auch
nicht mehr interessiert.
This Boy Timmy Overwatch 2 wurde angekündigt,
allerdings, wenn man ehrlich ist, ist Overwatch 2
eher ein Addon
für Overwatch 1,
beziehungsweise ein leichtes Upgrade.
Was einfach 2 heißt, aber
nicht wirklich so ein
hundertprozentig neues Game.
1,5 ist aufgerundet, 2.
So kann man das auch sehen. Quickmuffs.
Maxi, findest du das neue
COD verkämmt
ohnegleichen
und es lässt mich
daran zweifeln,
ob die
Teams, außer die
für die Technik zuständig waren, die mal außen vor,
weil die Technik ist diesmal echt gut,
irgendwie in ihrem Leben schon mal einen Shooter entwickelt
haben. Also das
lässt mich echt zweifeln
an Infinity Ward.
Dass es auf so vielen Ebenen versagt,
ähm,
Modern Warfare,
das ist eigentlich unglaublich, ja.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt, dass
du Maps hast, wo du
in Sicht
des Gegners spawnst, beziehungsweise
auf einem
Fleck in Sicht der Gegner
und solche Dinger,
also echt keine Ahnung.
Maps ohne
Flow,
ein Headshot Multiplikator,
der nicht Leute fürs Aim
belohnt, sondern Leute für
Lucky Hits, Spray und
und Recoil, Lucky Headshot
Hits. Also
ich weiß nicht, also alles was
ich bisher von Modern Warfare
gesehen habe, wirkt gewollt und
nicht gekonnt. Schon ein bisschen
wie in der Beta sich abgezeichnet hat.
Weil es ja auch irgendwie nur eine gescheite Map
gibt. Aber vielleicht ist das
alles nicht so schlimm. Ich habe ja noch nicht viel gespielt,
aber sowas täuscht mich selten.
Weil ich die Beta rauf und runter
gespielt habe und da ist kein großer Unterschied dazwischen.
Ja Evoli, das hätte
mich auch geflasht. Irgendwie was
abgedreht ist, ja. Korean
Snake, das Gefühl hat man echt.
Die schlagen auf ihre Tastatur rum, so lange bis ein neues
Call of Duty rauskommt.
So fühlt sich das an manchen
Stellen in Infinity, äh
in manchen Stellen in Modern Warfare auch an.
So einfach, einfach mal eine Runde, einfach mal
eine Runde, äh hier
Phaserolled
neues Call of Duty fertig.
Was brauchen wir? Moment, was?
Modern Warfare. Phaserolled, Phaserolled,
Phaserolled Game ist fertig.
So fühlt sich das an manchen Stellen an.
Was sie da getrieben haben.
Als Set erstellt,
klauen höchstpersönlich zu viel
Phaserolled auf dem Level Editor.
Ja, Maurice.
Acht ich mir.
Huge!
10 Euro! Von?
Also ich rechne mal 1 Bit, 1
Cent, das kommt so gefällt.
Agire89, danke für die 6 Jahre,
welche ich dich schon schaue.
1 Kilo Bit geht sich...
Ähm, ja, dann ist es
eben 1 Kiwi Bit.
Und kein Kilo Bit.
Ganz einfach, easy.
Wie lange streamst
du heute? Na ja, eigentlich bin ich jetzt fertig.
Wollte ich Blizzcon streamen und meinen
Cent dazu geben, meinen YouTube Post habe ich schon wieder gelöscht.
Mach ja manchmal super YouTube Ankündigungen,
aber halt immer selten.
Deswegen kann ich eigentlich nur sagen, Puder muss los.
Es sei denn,
ihr habt noch super komplizierte Fragen, die wir
jetzt erörtern müssen im Stream, ja.
Ansonsten gucke ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
Overwatch World Cup. Gucken wir mal,
was für Games jetzt als nächstes kommen.
German Paid TV?
Moment.
Overwatch World Cup läuft auf
irgendeinem Paid TV? What?
Nein, nein, den Overwatch World Cup, den darf man
definitiv nicht restreamen.
Es sei denn, man ist offizieller
Caster oder offizieller Channel oder so.
Nein, nein, das geht nicht.
Cyrus durfte den restreamen, beziehungsweise
nicht restreamen, der war
dabei, ja.
Stimmt, Evoli, du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Yes, yes.
Ah, yes.
Äh, wo ist es denn hier?
Ah ja, Group A, B.
Wollte ich mal hier gewinnen,
Südkorea, was sonst? Hier gewinnt
wahrscheinlich
Deutschland oder
Kanada? Schwierig.
Schwierig, ja.
Aber hier gewinnt, die Gruppe gewinnt
definitiv Südkorea, alles andere
wäre absoluter Wahnsinn, ja.
Deutschland ist ja leider
raus
aus dem World Cup, dank diesem
komischen Single Elimination.
Ne, warte mal, war Single Elimination?
Ja, war
Single Elimination, ne? Dank diesem
komischen Single Elimination konnten sie halt auch nur
zwei Games machen.
Wie ist Batman für die Leute, ja?
Die da hingefahren sind jetzt.
Und irgendwie auch ein bisschen viel Batman für die Leute,
die gespendet haben.
Ich will aber nicht sagen, dass sie schlecht gespielt haben,
dass die Leute enttäuscht sein sollen oder so,
sondern halt viel Batman für Single Elimination.
Single Elimination in so einem Turnier ist halt
Fail, Alter.
Was hat sich da Blizzard dabei gedacht?
Gegen wen haben die gespielt?
Äh, Russland und Hongkong?
Ne. Taipei? Ne.
Gegen was war mal?
Kannst du dir gleich sagen.
Die haben gespielt gegen Russland,
gegen Russland haben sie verloren.
Russland haben sie verloren, davor haben sie gewonnen
gegen Hongkong.
It's Win
It's Loss
Three Out und
Zero
Breed, keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt.
Ne, China gewinnt nicht.
Pavilion Man. Es gewinnt
Südkorea.
Ich glaub, es steht nichts anderes zur Diskussion,
als dass Südkorea den Overwatch World Cup gewinnt.
Es ist eigentlich auch gar nicht möglich.
Also,
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Ich weiß, ich bin nicht der große Fußballkenner
und ich bring selten Fußballvergleiche, ja?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
als Griechenland Europameister
geworden ist, wo wirklich
keine Sau damit gerechnet hat, dass Griechenland
Europameister wird? Das ist schon ewig her, ja?
Ähm,
dass
Südkorea
nicht
World Cup Winner wird,
finde ich noch
unwahrscheinlicher, als dass damals Griechenland
Europameister geworden ist.
Also, es ist, es steht eigentlich für mich
komplett außer Frage,
dass Südkorea einfach jedes Spiel
und wenn nicht sogar jede Map
easy gewinnt.
Ich mein, guckt euch die Leute an.
Das sind die Besten, die du kriegen
kannst. Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
das sind aber, also, ob es jetzt die Besten
der Besten sind, kann man sich drüber streiten, weil die Besten der Besten sind
alle Koreaner, ähm,
aber es sind die Besten.
Mit, mit die Besten.
Bei den anderen
hast du halt immer mal wieder gute Leute
dazwischen, auch die man kennt.
Ähm, leider waren viele
World Cup Teams, haben sich zum größten Teil,
also jetzt, die hier mal außen vor,
die kennst du, die kennst du, die kennst du,
Surefour kennst du, Mangachu kennst du, Note kennst du,
XQC kennst du, Grimso kennst du, Bunny kennst du,
den kenn ich jetzt nicht.
Ähm, also
von denen kennst du auch viele, aber
viele World Cup Teams waren halt auch, sagen wir mal so,
Hälfte aus ziemlichen No-Names besetzt.
Das soll nicht heißen, dass die schlecht spielen, halt einfach nur, dass
Spieler sind, die man nicht so kennt. Ähm,
jetzt von den verbleibenden
sind natürlich die Stars dabei,
aus der Overwatch League. Ähm,
den haben wir, ich hab mir die Teams gar nicht angeguckt.
Also hier kennst du mehr oder weniger alle von,
Dekati kenn ich nicht. Hier kennst du auch alle von.
Äh, hier kennst,
kenn ich ehrlich gesagt,
kaum jemand von.
Aber ich erfolg Overwatch auch nicht mehr so großartig.
Äh, Sun kennt man, Leaf kennt man,
allerdings, den hier kennst du, TechSaxon3,
macht mir jetzt nix.
Den anderen kenn ich auch nicht.
Ähm, Tori kenn ich,
KSF kenn ich, Sinatra kennt man auch. Ich mein,
der war Dings, ähm, MVP
von der letzten Overwatch League Siege.
Bass kennt man super gerne, Mothcat und Ruckus kennt man auch.
Äh, United Kingdom, KSP
kennt man, Kip kennt man auch, der ist ja schon ewig dabei.
Der hat uns mal im ESL Weekly Cup so krass
gelaunt damals. Ähm, Spax kennt man,
Fusions kenn ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt, aber ich guck auch nicht mehr so viel Overwatch League.
Boombox kennt man, Kruise
kennt man auch.
Wo ist eigentlich, wo ist eigentlich hier
TheFran, wo ist unser McDonalds-Mann für Dänemark?
Bin ich am Start.
Äh, Shaxx kennt man, Fischer kennt man,
Kalex kennt man, Rest von
weiß ich nicht. Äh,
Swain, Zillow kennt man,
die hier kennt man auch.
Push kennt man auch.
Russia,
da hört's jetzt bei mir schon, bei mir schon
Shadowburn, klar. Aber sonst hört's
bei mir ein bisschen auf. Und Niederlande,
Niederlande muss ich
ehrlich sagen, kenn ich noch nicht.
Guck mal, die Teams so richtig, wo die für
spielen.
Bist du noch wach genug, um mir eine
Wine-Pfeifert-Frage zu bewahren?
Das kommt drauf an, wenn es eine excellent, äh,
exquisite Frage ist, dann schon.
Ey, Sibaro, frag mal.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich aufgehen, klar.
Hahaha, Pfeifert-Frage.
Richtig, Pfeifert-Frage.
Ja, Sibaro, die einzige Sache ist da eigentlich,
äh, oder die, sag mal,
die beste Sache, die du machen kannst, du musst aus der Masse
der Leute, die auch alle
auf dein Physik-Grill sind, musst du
herausstechen. Wie du das machst,
ist individuell, das kann ich dir
jetzt nicht sagen, aber du musst, du musst
herausstechen, ja. Wie du das machst,
kann ich dir nicht sagen. Wenn ich
der Einzige bin, aber ganz schön wenig,
oder? Den Subbutton-Spam,
das ist natürlich auch eine Variante.
Ich leihe dir einfach, Sibaro,
ich leihe dir meinen Twitter-Account, da kannst
du sagen, du bist krasser Influencer.
Und dann, ähm, dann
geht das. Dann ist das easy.
Hehehehehe.
Dann ist
easy, das ist kein Problem mehr.
Sag bloß nicht, dass du bei der Bahn arbeitest,
ich glaub, das zieht nicht so gut.
Ne, ich kann nicht jedem meinen Twitter-Account leihen,
ja. Also, der Sibaro,
ich mein, der ist ja quasi unser, unser, äh,
Cute-Chat-Mod Nummer 1.
Da kann man das schon mal machen.
Was für China? Sollte der World Cup,
glaub ich, auch nicht unmöglich sein. Doch.
Gegen Südkorea, das sieht niemand
Land gegen Südkorea.
Wo sind, was sind denn die nächsten Games, die
jetzt hier kommen? Was, was sind
denn, was sind denn die nächsten
Games, die kommen?
Zeig mal her.
Dänmark gegen China.
Na gut.
Dänmark gegen China, ich
hab, ich kenn die Teams,
keine Ahnung.
Ich könnte China gewinnen, ich hab keinen Schimmer.
Davon bin ich nicht mehr zu weit drin, ne.
Welche Ressourcen kannst du empfehlen zum
Programmiersprachen lernen?
Kommt auf die Programmiersprache an, ne.
Sag mal Leute, heute ist Freitag, ne.
Das Morgen früh ist kein
Aufwachstream, erst übermorgen.
Ja. Ich hab übrigens vor,
mit, ähm,
zwei
Pros, also nicht, also
nicht, also Pro wie Professional
und nicht wie, wie Bro,
ähm,
mit zwei Pros,
zwei, äh, Kot-Pros,
sofern's sowas in Deutschland in der
Art und Weise überhaupt gibt.
Mal den Competitive Aspekt von,
äh, Modern Warfare zu beleuchten.
Und ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen,
die sind nicht allzu glücklich über das
Game.
Hat Mixer schon versucht dich zu
kaufen? Na, no comment, no comment.
Ich sag zu laufenden Sachen, sag ich nix.
Zum Beispiel C++.
C++ ist schwierig zu lernen.
Da würd ich sagen, kauft ihr ein ordentliches
Buch, was sich mit
Modern C++ beschäftigt.
Kann ich leider keine Empfehlung geben.
Wie wäre es mit einem Streaming
mit jemand, der Kot Modern Warfare gut findet?
Gibt's da überhaupt jemand,
der das nicht nur sagt, um die Leute zu erfreuen,
sondern da wirklich davon
innerlich überzeugt ist?
Würdest du Chromium oder Firefox empfehlen?
Nö.
Firefox ist für mich immer noch der beste Browser.
Aber ich verwende öfters Chrome
als Firefox.
Yes.
Weiß auch nicht warum.
Lebt dein MMX 300 immer noch?
Ja, hab ich gerade auf hier.
Der Shox wird wahrscheinlich auch dabei sein.
Du hast es geschafft.
Mein einziges Problem mit Firefox ist,
dass ich nicht casten kann.
Ja gut, dann Chrome.
Es heißt ja nicht, dass man Chrome cast.
Maps gut.
Es gibt Leute, die die Modern Warfare Maps
gut finden.
Was ist gut daran,
wenn man in den spawnenden Gegner gucken kann?
Oder wenn man
vor dem Gegner spawnt?
Oder eher Eberdio.
Aber JavaScript kann casten.
Oh, der war schlecht.
Naja gut.
Ich will ja keinem verbieten,
was er da, wenn das einer gut findet,
ist okay.
Gut, Leute.
Excellent Stream.
Cute Chat.
Wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Stream.
Oder im nächsten Video.
Oder in beidem.
Sub Button drücken.
Für mehr FPS.
Und High IQ.
Guckt auf YouTube rein,
guckt auf Twitter vorbei.
Dicker Teufel.
Twitch Prime Sub.
Big Brain Sub.
High IQ.
Boost für den Chat.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.